Emmy Awards were last night and here
with a wrap-up of last night's events is
our own josh redmond the asthmatic
narcoleptic entertainment correspondent
with Tourette's syndrome stop him now
thanks Conan well once again the big
winners last night did not come from the
traditional broadcast networks but from
premium cable and the streaming service
Netflix no surprise really because HBO
has dominated quality drama with
offerings like Game of Thrones and
Netflix has been acquiring so much
content it's got the capacity not only
to take risks but have them pay off
Julia Louie Dreyfus took home her fifth
consecutive Emmy Award for Lead Actress
in a comedy series a streak unparalleled
in Emmy history Candice Bergen also won
five Emmys in this category but it took
her seven years to do it so that's kind
of a big achievement okay well Thank You
Josh ed good good job I guess is there a
problem Conan okay I'll say it
you're the asthmatic narcoleptic
entertainment correspondent with
Tourette's syndrome so naturally I kept
expecting you to run out of breath or
fall asleep suddenly or start cursing I
think we all kind of expected it I
understand I use my inhaler right before
the segment and I'm on a new medication
that controls my sleep cycle also sudden
outbursts of profanity are a common
misconception about Tourette's syndrome
[Laughter]
just that we were all kind of I don't
know
waiting for some yeah comedy thing to
happen so I thought you might be I
thought you might be and that's why I
prepared this brief montage of suburban
dads getting hit in the penis enjoy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alright well josh redmond the the
asthmatic narcoleptic entertainment
correspondent with Tourette's syndrome
Thank You Conan and
[Applause]
looks like a breaking right back Andy
samberg's here stick around
[Applause]
you